[Music]
this private property sir it certainly
is private property not your property
sir
mrs. Henderson called she said there's a
black man dressed up like a cow on crack
cocaine harassing and goes yeah she did
that go was arrested me agree with me
that go really one of the guns Satyam
why did it go Jesse said Amen way up in
this pin which it could I know you're in
a cow I said the story doesn't check out
the story doesn't check out it was he
said but what is the chamber that see
black man costume crack cocaine
harassing my goats trespassing on my
property
okay you know what let's refute those
one by one okay I'm a little refuting
one by one crackhead I can't refute that
one okay dress up like a cow I'm open to
ting fine harassing my goats that I
didn't do because I was over here this
month this little don't paw at him yeah
son of a bitch god damn it god damn it
right god damn the crackling fast he's
headed straight to straight to Mountain
Lion Country you know what they'll take
care of him my old lines will get them
it's a circle of life
oh hey what you got there little
roommate blu-ray disc system blu-ray
disc system yeah you're worth going to
jail for that I'm $700 DVD player 700 or
manatee they drop these down to like 250
to 69 right now No oh yeah hey now if I
watch blu-rays on my - is it gonna have
letterbox who's gonna be full frame hey
what you got there Oh a little wave
plant got a question here those things
play on ploughs mozar just CRT no no
this play on clouds
CRT DLP he shall feed beef any kind of
format you hear how much you pay for
that one right there this one right here
yeah oh this looks free from the App
Store hey Junior
yeah you still got that 8-track tape
player yeah I don't think those are work
on a blu-ray
[Music]